when it comes to Islam especially in the
beginning when you know you heard Andrew
take and burden all that and up until
now when you're learning all these
things about some I know you mentioned
scientific Miracles what has really
stood out to you that makes you think
wow you know that's something that's
special because you seem to have a keen
sense of Interest I'd probably say the
scientific Miracles that's kind of more
of the stuff that I'm into so hearing
all of the Miracles that couldn't have
possibly been known at the time but are
proven to be true now I probably thought
thought that that was the most
remarkable thing inside of it what would
you say is it the scientific stuff or is
it like I feel like it'd be the
similarities for you the scientific
stuff is fascinating another thing is um
it's not in the Quran but the biggest
thing I've noticed about Islam is like
the Brotherhood with it so I've talked
about this there's like this might be a
bad example but with like black dudes or
something if they're at a party where
it's like mostly white people they have
like that connection and with Christians
and stuff I feel like there isn't that
as much of a connection where you know
you meet another Christian it's like oh
that's it's like everyone it just feels
like everyone's a Christian if you tell
someone that it doesn't really mean as
much but then I've been out with Muslims
where they meet other Muslims and
they're like Habibi and then they're
like um they have like that Brotherhood
and I'm like I don't know that that also
stands out to me and it it oh go ahead
I'll let you know that's that's the
majority of my point and I I countered
you on this I counted you on this
because he made it seem in his first
commentary on it that it was like no one
else does this and I'm like all right
that's not true that's not true first of
all just culturally Italians do like the
men there's there's a handshake and a
hug and a kiss among men uh and it's
regular and it's you know it's very warm
um now that I'm in a different type of
church where I'm now making uh
acquaintances and friends with people
who are can actually I can actually talk
about the Bible with there is like this
whole other level connection so what I
think the difference is is is that you
know you guys take your a religion you
know you let your religion drive your
life
and so here I'm finding Christians who
let their religion who let their belief
in God let God run you know the whole
Jesus Take the Wheel thing is very real
and uh it's not just an expression that
you use when things are going wrong like
just let them drive all the time because
he knows better is is really more of the
mindset and so I I feel that with those
you know poisons to use an Italian
expression and it's a it which is a
means brother is a Brotherhood you know
or Sisterhood and so I I just don't
think it's as unique as Sunny does but I
think the real point is that Sonny's
impressed by it and I think it is
impressive you know that that closeness
and that Brotherhood that before we came
on live tonight Rami you you said the
other brothers aren't here yet and I
said oh your brothers like I thought you
were real you know you were three
brothers and he said no no just in the
Brotherhood I was all right cool yeah
I'm making so and I think that's
beautiful it's it goes to say that like
it can be found elsewhere it's not just
in Islam where you find this Brotherhood
or Sisterhood as well for the Sisters
but it's in Islam we're told by the
Prophet Muhammad in one of the hadiths
now the hadiths or narrations it's
basically what the prophet said and
they're all authenticated so any Hadith
that we take to be as like okay he
actually said this there's a chain of
narration that you have Scholars who are
actually doing due diligence and like
really just going through a process to
either credit it or discredit it now in
one of these hadiths the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he said that you should love for your
brother what you love for yourself and
that's something that if you look in the
Bible it's fairly in the it's fairly in
the same that you should love for
um exactly it's the same it's the same
message correct but the thing is like
where do you see it most applied is for
the most part in this land like you just
see people even people that don't really
practice they're Muslim but they they
don't really practice even they have
that Brotherhood and that Sisterhood
with other Muslims it's a very very it's
a very amazing thing to be honest where
you could be Muslim and someone all the
way across the world you've never met
them you don't know them you don't know
anything about them but because you're
Muslim because you share their faith and
because they love for you what they will
love for themselves if you were going to
go over across seas and be with them
they would accept you into their house
they would take care of you as if you
were their own like the the hospitality
the family type vibe that I've felt from
Muslims the only other place that I've
ever felt that is my own family
so it's there's something there for sure
that's cool and I and I have felt it
outside of my own family and in other
communities
um so I stand by my like it's not unique
but it is special it is special no
matter where it's coming from but but I
do love I do love that it is it is so so
part of your call your culture to me
that makes it much stronger and and much
more credible oh I want to go back to
the the original question though like so
he said you know what was it that's most
interesting because that that was really
what you where you came up that you
really loved that about it
um the scientific
um Revelations that were passed on to
Muhammad are killer that is so cool I
can't say enough about the
um learning about that and knowing what
I know about you know Modern Life I just
found that to give tremendous
credibility to Muhammad as a prophet
because there's no other way he could
have known that you know yes some may
what they did with Jesus call him a
sorcerer or something you know like
whatever like okay that's like a vacuous
uh argument right against it so I find
that to be so credible and impressive
and and just fascinating but then there
are other things that really stood out
for me that I haven't had time to
research like uh somewhere in the Quran
and said that Jesus was talking and you
was a talking baby I was just going to
mention that talking baby like I speak
like I I haven't had time to really
research it on my end on the Christian
side but you know in 12 years of
Catholic school I think I would have
remembered that and I don't think it's
something that's in the Bible again I
have to confirm that so you know that's
where I get a little um like the
historical the historical differences
and doesn't the Quran say Jesus wasn't
crucified or um yeah right and and there
was actually a lot of a lot of
historical proof that he was so those
two things are are sticking points for
me and it doesn't discredit the religion
for me because I you know but it does
historically I I need to do a lot more
homework because I I do tend to believe
something that was written within a
hundred years of Jesus's death as being
more accurate than something that was
written about Jesus 600 years later
right yeah whether it was written by
Muhammad or anybody yeah yeah that's 100
100 yeah so that's very fair oh sorry
sorry please yeah no that's it that's it
those are a really super interesting
points though all of them I was gonna I
was gonna say that's always been a
bigger struggle of mine with religion is
differentiating like myth with what's
factual so we'd hear stuff like Adam and
Eve and the Ark and stuff and that's
considered like not you know uh
historical truth but it's supposed to
mean something else so then I would hear
it like walking on water and all those
other stories and I would have trouble
differentiating what is meant to be
taken literally and what's meant to be
taken as I guess myth is that is do you
guys know
um in your knowledge because I don't it
is the is the arc for example meant to
be a myth or is it meant to be a
historical you know fact that we
understood and that one day an
archaeologist May dig up that Arc yeah
so it's weird yeah with Islam when it
comes to these stories we don't have
this um this worry that oh there's no
historical evidence of Moses therefore
he didn't exist because what's really
important is when you're looking at a
religion in regards to any kind of
secular study like history or archeology
it's very important to understand this
both the religion and the study itself
when you look at history and I think
this is something Bart Ehrman mentioned
who's a historian and New Testament
scholar he said that historical truths
I'm going to paraphrase are not like
facts historical facts are not like it
100 happened like you exist and I exist
as a fact you know historical truths are
only probabilistic truths the job of the
historian is to tell you what most
likely happened because using you can
have a document that says that says you
know um on Hobie Ramen and arm wrestle
but obviously that's not possible so
that document is clearly wrong
so obviously that document is clearly
wrong so the job of the historian is to
show what most likely happened so you'll
you'll and by the way I want to add that
the reason kind of Christians or people
who who believe in the Bible some of
them want to say that these are myths is
because of things like you know when
Evolution comes they some of them kind
of folded over and with things like the
belief that the universe is six thousand
years old I know not everyone Christian
not every Christian believes that but
some of them have adopted Well it can't
be literal um for these reasons you know
that that would mean the flood would
have would would be less than six
thousand years ago and there was no
great flood six thousand years ago there
was a flood much much earlier than that
a great flood and if you look up
Mountain Judy it's in Turkey you'll see
some pictures of uh crevice that looks
like a boat landed in it and it's really
interesting because side note the Quran
says that the ark landed on Mount Judy
so that's why it was so fascinating for
Muslims when they see us wild yeah see
that's cool all right make sure you guys
like subscribe and if you're interested
in learning how to dominate social media
and make money online I'm having a crazy
sale with my Online Academy where I
teach you all my strategies how I've hit
over a hundred thousand Subs in four
months how I've generated five million
dollars using organic marketing so DM me
bank if you guys want to learn more
about about that
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]